قال مصدر رسمي تركي للجزيره انه تم ابلاغه
الجانب الروسي بعدم قبول تركي لانتشار
الشكليه للقوات النظام السوري في مناطق ما
تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه واضاف المصدر
الرسمي التركي للجزيره انه تم التاكيل
للجانب الروسي على ضروره حل ما تعرف بقوه
سوريا ديمقراطيه او اخراجها من مناطق
النفوذ الروسي واوضح انه تم يعدله كافه
التجهيزات العسكريه واللوجستيه اللازمه
لتنفيذ العمليه العسكريه الشماليه سوريا
المصدر الرسمي والتركي كشفنا الجزيره ان
هدف المرحله الاولى من العمليات العسكريه
هو السيطره على رفعت ومنبج وعين العرب اشر
الى ان الجانب الامريكي بتتفاهمه للمطالب
التركيه وان المعلومات المتوفره لدى
الجانب التركي تشير الى ان الامريكيين
انسحبوا من بعض المواقع
وقال الناطق باسم الرئاسه التركيه ابراهيم
قليا ان العمليه العسكريه التركيه البريه
قد تبدا في اي وقت وفق ما تحدده اوليات
اولوياتها وان ذلك يعتمده على تقييم
المراجع المعنيه قال ان اكد ان تركيا لم
تستهدف حتى الان اي جنود امريكيين او روس
وان هدفها الوحيد هو وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه الموجوده في شمال سوريا
تتزامن هذه التصريحات مع التجديد القوات
التركيه مواقع تعرف بقوته سوريا
الديمقراطيه في شمال الشرقيه سوريا وقد
افادت مصادر محليه من الجزيره بان
المدفعيه التركيه قصفت مواقع على ما تعرف
بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه في قرن بمحيطها
عين العرب كوباني وبلده في تل رفعت بري في
حلب
الى ذلك قللت انقره من بواعي في القلق
الدولي واكد المندوب التركي او لدى الامم
المتحده فريدون هذه سينر لاوغلو ان الحديث
عن ان تاثير العمليات العسكريه سيكون
سلبيا على مواجهه تنظيم تنظيم الدوله
تحديدا هو غير واقعي
ات مكافحه الارهاب لحمايه شعبنا وضمان امن
حدودنا في ممارسه الحق الطبيعي في الدفاع
عن النفس على النحو المنصوص عليه في
الماده الحاديه والخمسين من ميثاق الامم
المتحده ووفقا لقرارات مجلس الامن الدولي
بشان مكافحه الارهاب التصريحات التي تعرب
عن القلق من ان عمليات مكافحه الارهاب
التي نقوم بها ضد حزب العمال الكردستاني
قد تؤثر سلبا على القتال ضد داعش غير
واقعيه الحقيقه هي ان داعش لا يزال يشكل
تهديدا بالدرجه الاولى للدول المجاوره
بسبب الاعمال والاستراتيجيات الخاطئه لمن
يدلي بهذه الانواع من التصريحات
في المقابله
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلومه عبدي في
حديث
ان قوتهم لا تزال تخشى بدا هجوم البري
تركيه رغم التقنيات الامريكيه وطلب عبده
واشنطن برساله تحضيريه اقوى لتركيا بعد حش
مزيدا من التعزيزات العسكريه عند الحدود
مع سوريا
اعرب المتحدث باسمي وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه باتريك رايدر عن قلق الولايات
المتحده من التصعيد في شمال شرق سوريا على
الحدود التركيه رايدر حتى على ضبط النفس
محدرا من ان اجتياحا بريا تركيا في تلك
المنطقه سيهدد ما انجز في محاربه تنظيم
الدوله
من التصعيد في شمال سوريا والعراق على
الحدود مع تركيا ونحث على ضبط النفس وسط
التوترات في تلك المنطقه فحصوله غزو بري
سيجدد بشكل كبير ما انجزه العالم ضد تنظيم
الدوله وسيزعزع الاستقرار في المنطقه ونحن
نعترف بمخاوف في تركيا الامنيه المشروعه
حياه الاعمال الارهابيه داخل حدودها
ونواصل ايضا قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في
القتال ضد تنظيم الدوله
وقل المتحدث باسمي وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
ان الولايات المتحده قلصت الدورياتها
شماليه سوريا واضافا رايدر ان واشنطن لا
تزال تركز على القضاء على تنظيم الدوله
بشراكه مع قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه التي
خلصت بدورها دورياتها ما استدعى فعل الشيء
نفسه لم نعد ننشر جنودنا ونظل مركزين على
محاربه تهديدات تنظيم الدوله ولم تتضاى
القدرتنا في ذلك الاطار لكننا خلصنا
دورياتنا في الوقت الحالي